but you only been out to discuss this is
David bond he's media correspondent at
the Financial Times David so were you
surprised at the decision that we're
going to get a referral probably no
surprise I think the market for quite a
while had been expecting that Caron
Bradley would refer this to the CMA and
of course she hasn't yet come to a final
decision but I think what was perhaps a
surprise that there was such a sort of
firm vote of confidence in Fox as a fit
and proper owner of a UK broadcasting
license and that perhaps the focus was
so much on plurality indeed now so the
plurality issue now Fox have offered
certain remedies to off common to the
CMA those haven't gone far enough for
Ofcom what can Fox do next well in fact
they did go far enough for Ofcom Ofcom
said they were happy that it would
mitigate these concerns over plurality
but it's Karin Bradley who's actually
asking for them to go a bit further and
at the moment they've offered to as we
heard their ring-fence
funding for five years and to set up an
independent editorial board but I think
what Karin Bradley would like to see and
this is maybe where the CMA will come in
it's more structural change perhaps a
separate company which of course was
what News Corporation offered back in
2010 last night what would that mean for
Sky News I mean is it strong enough to
be a standalone entity well that's one
of the big questions and in fact Ofcom
in its report raises questions about how
sustainable that would be if it is taken
out of the sky structure and whether it
would be able to stand on its own feet
financially but one possible option
which one analyst talked to me about
today was whether you could have sort of
a halfway house as sort of separate
subsidiary a bit like the open reach
solution which Ofcom came up with some
while ago with bt now we heard in the
addams package there from Tom Watson of
course now there's a bit of an irony in
Tom Watson's position because on the one
hand he's saying he doesn't want the
Murdoch Family Trust to have all this
control and yet on the other hand he
stood up in the Commons today and he
said well the Sun and newspapers like
that don't really have an influence
anymore well of course you know one of
the interesting things about this is
that the argument that Fox made was that
the growth of the multiple online
operators now BuzzFeed HuffPost Facebook
Twitter had some in some way diluted
Rupert Murdoch's control over media in
the UK but in fact Ofcom found the
opposite they said if anything
son has become more powerful online and
its reach has grown it's perhaps the
second biggest behind the BBC so there
are more questions about forever see
because of the internet not not reducing
its power now we heard that I mean Tom
Watson in the comments said he thought
the deal would go through Greg Dyke in
that package we just saw as well said
the same man dude do you think it's
inevitable that the CMA will allow this
deal to go through I think everyone is
expecting that eventually it will go
through I mean look at the shares they
run up 3% today I think that was a
reaction mainly to the fit and proper
clearance and eventually this deal will
go through and Fox are certainly
confident it will David bomb from the FT
appreciate you joining is good to see